et il est relâché criminelle pour
déposer des bons vins samedi après midi
dans des grands magasins à quelques
jours des fêtes de noël
7 décembre 1985 il ya 35 ans dans le
quartier de l'opéra à paris
deux bombes explosent à quelques minutes
d'intervalle la première aux galeries
lafayette
la seconde 300 mètres plus loin au
printemps haussmann
je viens de remonter l'egypte se fait
brûler son corps de la jeune verte
les explosions ont lieu en plein
préparatifs de noël les magasins sont
bondés le bilan est lourd
des dizaines de blessés certains
gravement le spectacle totalement
désolant je n'arrive pas à comprendre
que des gens du avec une telle lâcheté
peuvent déposer une bombe dans un grand
magasin à samedi après midi quelques
minutes après le drame les deux
explosions sont revendiquées via un
appel anonyme au bout du fil le flp le
front de libération de la palestine mais
la piste n'est pas crédible
elle est rapidement écartée par les
enquêteurs en revanche un témoignage
retient l'attention
effectivement aux galeries lafayette
juste a pas d'explosion
deux personnes auraient vu deux
personnes
deux autres personnes pardon sauter dans
une golf blanche immédiatement donc à
pas l'explosion c'est peut-être un taux
début d'un 10 voilà pour ce soir là
encore cette piste ne donne rien
les mois suivants d'autres attentats
similaires frappe la capitale notamment
aux champs elysées sur la place saint
michel ou encore au forum des halles
mais l'attentât le plus meurtrier
c'est celui de la rue de rennes le 17
septembre 1986 la rue de rennes offre ce
soir le spectacle d'un véritable hôpital
de nombreuses personnes recherchent
encore actuellement ceux ou celles qui
les accompagnaient chez tati en fin
d'après midi
bilan 7 morts 55 blessés c'est le
dernier d'une série de quatorze
attentats en un an
le premier d'entre eux étant celui des
grands magasins parisiens et tous
revendiqué par le hezbollah libanais à
noter qu'à l'époque la france soutient
l'irak alors en pleine guerre contre
l'iran parmi les membres du groupe
islamiste fouad ali salle et un tunisien
suspecté d'être l'organisateur présumé
les attentats en 1987 il est arrêté à
paris en compagnie de plusieurs de ses
complices
des dizaines de policiers surgissent
soudain entoure un taxi et ceinture
trois hommes ce sont les premières
arrestations d'un groupe de neuf
personnes huit hommes et une femme en
possession de passeports tunisien en
1990 le procès de fouad ali saleh
s'ouvre à paris pour sept rescapés
c'est un soulagement je n'ai pas de
haine ni d'esprit vengeance mais j'ai un
souci je pense très légitime de
connaître la vérité le 14 avril 1992
fouad ali saleh est condamné par la cour
d'assises spéciale de paris à la
réclusion criminelle à perpétuité
[Musique]